[Musique]
nous avons les outils pour empêcher cette nouvelle
vague de convoitise
de fermer nos entreprises nos
écoles notre société
comme nous l'avons vu se produire l'année dernière j'ai dit
depuis le début
que nous serons guidés par la science
aujourd'hui je pose  des mesures supplémentaires que
nous devrions prendre pour fournir
ces vaccins vitaux à plus d'américains d'
abord, nous allons fournir plus d'
incitations
pour encourager les américains non vaccinés à
se faire vacciner,
cela commence par un congé payé pour se faire vacciner,
donc aujourd'hui j'appelle tous les états  et
les gouvernements locaux à utiliser les fonds qu'ils
ont reçus, y compris du
plan de sauvetage américain
pour en donner 100 à quiconque se fait vacciner complètement,
je sais que la douleur que les gens se font vacciner
peut sembler injuste pour les gens qui se
sont déjà fait vacciner,
mais voici l'affaire si les incitations nous aident
vaincre ce virus, je crois que nous devrions les
utiliser,
nous vous en profitons tous